first things first discussions
reportedly of a
shorter preseason this does not surprise
me at all
i won't be surprised if there's
ultimately no preseason games maybe
scrimmages instead if that yes
they're gonna try to keep these guys in
her medically sealed containers until
it's time to play the games that count
why put guys on the field together
before you have to
so they're discussing cutting the
preseason in half
and again it may just be the first step
toward having no preseason at all
yeah well it makes sense i mean it
certainly does you know to what you just
said mike yeah they want to keep
everybody you know
sanctioned off from each other to where
we're not causing problems in the
pre-season before we even get to the
regular season where all of a sudden
copenhagen is starting to spread around
the nfl
so makes sense totally from that
standpoint
also i think it's a very good idea when
you just talk about player safety
and just the betterment of the nfl in
general
in fact of mike i mean you know a lot of
these guys yeah they're at home working
out
are they in tip-top shape no i would
doubt that
you know again there is something to
being in your facility on a daily
basis with people with the teammates and
coaches pushing you
uh the competitive nature and juices
start to flow out
of course the workouts are more rigorous
and
and and tough and everything about it so
i don't think the players are going to
be
necessarily in hitting pre-season
football
shape either you know come early august
that second weekend in august usually
when preseason football starts
and i don't think that would be fair to
them too and i think the nfl would be
smart to kind of ease everybody into
this a little bit more this year
so we don't lose a bunch of players the
first two weeks of training camp or the
first week of pre-season
because we've kind of rushed things
along too much and the players weren't
ready to go
july 28 is the target for most of the
teams to show up for training camp under
the cba
but there has been talk of players going
in
early to get themselves acclimated and
it's in their best interest it's in the
team's best interests and
you don't want guys to get injured look
you mentioned it's fair to the players
it is fair to the players but ultimately
the teams have
valuable assets they are trying to
protect
and that is i think paramount
in the minds of a lot of these coaches
and general managers you don't want to
have a rash of injuries
when you're dealing with guys who
haven't been under the supervision of
the team who've been working out at home
who
aren't in the same kind of shape that
they'd be in
and some guys who knows what kind of
shape they're in who knows what they've
really been doing who knows how
effective any of it is
and these are all concerns that i think
should manifest themselves
in players wanting to be there sooner
and teams definitely wanting them there
sooner so they can assess
where they are so they don't get anyone
injured by throwing them into the fray
too quickly
yeah i i think that's that's very real i
i think you have to be
very cognizant of that this year you
know and you're right mike i mean
there's going to be a faction of guys
and
you know i think it's going to break
down in like three different categories
when you talk about players
who uh dealing with this whole pandemic
and and not being at the facility
you're gonna have like one third of the
league that's gonna they they're gonna
approach it the way they always do and
be ready to go
you know you'll have another third of
the league that
i worked out and okay i look pretty good
i've gone to the gym and done some curls
and done some bench press so
when i walk in the facility come late
july
i'll have big muscles and fool everybody
but not necessarily going to mean you're
in football shape and then i think
you're going to have a third of guys who
are
yes just barely in good enough shape not
really
probably the type of human beings who
are going to stay on top of it on a
daily basis without somebody kind of
staying on top of them as well so that's
where it's going to get very interesting
and i think coaches are really going to
have to
gauge where players and teams are at
through conditioning tests and practice
and
you know listen to the players maybe
more than years and years past
when you were describing the guys who
are in the kind of shape where they look
good but they're not really ready to
play football it reminded
me of joey porter once being accused of
having popcorn muscles do you remember
that
i do remember that yes yeah remember
it's a quiz do you remember the do you
remember who it is
that said joey porter has popcorn
muscles um
i don't remember no it was your former
teammate brandon marshall who said why
did you reporter is soft he's not tough
he's got popcorn muscles that's not our
accusation joey
i'm just i'm just taking a trip down
memory lane is inspired by
a comment made by chris sims brandon
marshall once said that
joey porter has popcorn muscles all
right um i'm not messing with either one
of those guys that you know there's
things you know in life
okay and one of those things to know in
life after
seeing joey porter and brandon marshall
and being a teammate is uh there's
certain people you know you can take
in in life and then there's certain
people you know you just shouldn't mess
with and those two guys i'm not messing
with
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports